salut c'est piquer sur brute
[Musique]
Oh
donc c'était il y a 30 ans et Ronnie
m'a demandé de l'aider à délimiter sa terre,
ce que nous avons fait pour la protéger légalement
dans la constitution du gouvernement brésilien
et  maintenant, le
gouvernement brésilien dit qu'il veut
déchirer ces traités contre la
Constitution, c'est un problème très grave
et j'espère que les
freins et contrepoids au sein du
gouvernement brésilien empêcheront que
cela se produise
[Musique]
c'est le  le plus gros problème auquel nous sommes confrontés en tant
qu'êtres humains peut-être jamais sur la planète
et donc je pense que nos politiciens
doivent aborder ce problème, il ne sera pas
changé par des individus par vous ou moi,
il changera être changé par les
gouvernements, nous devons donc forcer nos gouvernements à
prenez le problème au sérieux et jusqu'à ce que nous le
fassions, le navire continuera d'aller dans la
mauvaise direction Je ne peux pas faire demi-
tour vous ne pouvez pas faire demi-tour les
gouvernements peuvent l'UE Chine États-
Unis mais c'est le cas
Je pense que c'est une bonne stratégie
d'être optimiste, ah ça a toujours été comme
ça, bien que cela devienne plus difficile
d'être optimiste, mais je dis que la seule
façon de changer, c'est si nous convainquons nos
politiciens que c'est un vrai  problème
monsieur  Trump dit que c'est une blague un canular pas
vrai
[Musique]
vous